today is all about inside xbox we got to
see our first peek at assassin's creed
valhalla gameplay
kind of two new horror games are on
their way to the xbox series x and dirt
5 was announced i'm persia and you've
reached your save state for thursday may
7th
as promised during inside xbox we got to
see some assassin's creed valhalla
gameplay
allegedly the trailer doesn't show much
in terms of combat or exploration
but does show up various locations like
feasting halls long boats castles and
sprawling hills
we also get a good look at avery's raven
which is taking the place of the
traditional assassin's creed eagle
we also get to see some stunning shots
of average hidden blade and dual wielded
axes which will no doubt
be in your combat arsenal valhalla is
one of the games that will have smart
delivery support so regardless of which
xbox console you buy the game for
it will be available on all other xbox
devices and
optimized for it you can find the full
trailer and a ton of coverage on
gamespot right now
we even have a video up of everything
you need to know so far about the story
and the characters to help you stay up
to date
it's official yakuza like a dragon is a
series x launch title
and it's also coming with smart delivery
support like a dragon released earlier
this year in japan but will now be
released worldwide on the series x at
launch
this is a fresh start for the series and
follows former yakuza member kasuga
ichiban
as the series central hero cosmo kiryu's
story is now wrapped up if smart
delivery isn't enough to get you on the
skype train
then maybe cross safe support will this
means you can play it on xbox one then
jump right over to the series x version
with your current save progress
and vice versa if you're not already is
this enough to get you on the yakuza
bandwagon
blooper team the devs behind blair witch
and observation are teaming up with
silent hill composer
akira yamaoka for a brand new
psychological horror game
called the medium the medium's name is
miriam and she's trying to solve a child
murder but the game's theme around
duality is going to make that a little
creepier than normal
the player will have to navigate through
the real world and the spirit world to
find answers to this terrifying mystery
with involvement from akira yamaoka for
the soundtrack the meeting's shaping up
to be a
full and chilling experience and i can't
wait to learn more
another game scorn is also coming to the
xbox series x
and the trailer alone triggered my
triple phobia
more times than i care to admit in terms
of gameplay scorn takes cues from
metroidvanias you'll unlock skills and
weapons that let you explore new areas
each area will have its own theme and
story that contributes to the overall
narrative of the game in terms of art
h.r giger is the inspiration which
makes sense if you've seen his work he's
best known for the xenomorph in
alien scoring hasn't been confirmed for
smart delivery but we do know that it's
coming to game pass
is it too creepy for you or are you
excited
codemasters rally racing game dirt 5 has
been announced
the trailer showed a wide variety of
environments from icy roads to muddy
forests
and also showcased the full day night
cycles this time around weather effects
will be a part of the races to help
ensure that all the factors will make
every race unique
dirt 5 is heading to xbox one and the
series x
and we'll have smart delivery support we
have the full trailer up on game spot
right now
madden 21 will also support smart
delivery
super bowl champion and kansas city
chiefs quarterback patrick mahomes
appeared on the stream to talk all about
it
mahomes said the new madden will focus
on the feel of the field and we'll see
more
soon we didn't see much of the game
itself but it's good that madden 21 will
have smart delivery support since the
game will likely launch
before the series x comes out which team
are you taking to the super bowl in
madden 21
that's a wrap on thursday's news but if
you want all the coverage from inside
xbox then make sure you catch it on
gamespot i'm persia and you can follow
me on twitter at persia underscore xo
and we'll catch you on the next one take
care
[Music]
you